have your time in
hell but then he says then we shall
deliver those that were God-fearing and
the evildoers we shall leave there
hobbling on their knees so some of the
good Muslims or some of the you know
relatively good Muslims they will get
plucked out of hell right Allah will
bring them out of hell um while leaving
the evildoers
there okay
yeah now so even in Islam everyone's
going to hell all the even as a Believer
you're going to
hell but Jesus says you believe in me
and you'll be coming to my father's
house you won't you'll be saved period
you're not going to hell he's he's
delivered you fully in Islam you still
go to
hell but then how do you get delivered
Out of Hell watch watch watch how you're
delivered Out of Hell watch what the
watch what the Hadith says
here this is how you're delivered Out of
Hell one second let me show you this I'm
just showing you that it's not just oh
you know as a Muslim we just ask for
forgiveness and Allah forgives us nah
watch watch
this watch this
2767 watch this what is it that gets you
out of Hellfire
here it is let's go ahead and share this
tab it says this isai Muslim 2767
B Abu Abu BDA reported on the authority
of his father that Allah's Apostle said
so this is what Muhammad teaches no
muslim would die but Allah would admit
in his stead a Jew or a Christian in
Hellfire
so what's going to be saving the Muslims
from hell what's going to be their
deliverance from hell when Allah brings
them out of hell it's going to be
replacing them with a Jew and a
Christian that's going to be their
salvation matter of fact when we read
up this one this haddi says when it will
be the day of Resurrection Allah will
deliver to every Muslim a Jew or a
Christian and say that is your rescue
from
Hellfire so while we have Jesus the holy
Son of God the Divine Son of God who
willfully and is capable to give his
life for us and to Deliver Us From Hell
be our rescue from Hellfire right by
laying down his own life for us in Islam
you have sinful Jews and Christians who
are dying and
replacing Muslims in Hellfire and
getting punished for the sins of the
Muslims
so he will put like Jews and Christians
for no reason and replace them for
Muslims for Muslims now now let me get
you this there are some people that say
well you know these these Jews and
Christians they denied The Message of
Islam anyway so they they they're going
to hell they deserve it
however even if we can accept that
explanation here that doesn't change the
fact that the Muslims who deserve hell
are having their sins being put on the
Jew and the Christians so that they can
go
free that's what's happening here
they're being replaced they're being
substituted yeah I got the point yeah
yeah I got you this is Islam bro well
Jesus says the
opposite Jesus says you come to me I'll
give you rest for your souls it's a
guarantee
he says you believe in me you I will
bring you to myself you will be in my
father's house no guessing about
it all right now let's explain this uh
what it is that Jesus was what it means
that Jesus is dying for our sins doesn't
mean that we don't sin anymore does does
sin just disappear or something no what
it means that he dies for our sins is
that he dies um and he takes on the
punishment or the consequence that we
deserve so the price for sin is death
that's the Wage of Sin that's what it
costs the wages of sin is death Eternal
separation from God okay that's what the
punishment of sin is that's what the the
wage is all right
now um so when we say that Jesus died
for our sins means that he paid the
price he paid the debt that we owe we
owed God death and separation that's
what we owed Jesus came and died in our
place so that we wouldn't have
to and so that means now that the wrath
of God and the punishment that we
deserve Jesus Took upon himself and so
now we are now made we are reconciled
back to God we're back in his good
graces as long as we believe in the
sacrifice that Jesus gave as we We
Believe and we accept that atonement
sacrifice that gift of Grace then we are
reconciled back to him now do I still
sin even as a Believer yes I do still as
long as I have this mortal flesh that
I'm inhabiting and walking around in I
will sin in my life I will what so what
what what is it then what it is is that
now I have the grace of God that covers
me when I do
fall and he helps me get back up again
I'm as a believer I'm living a life of
constant repentance and gratitude the
life that I live is a life that is
continuously turned back to Christ even
when I fall short I get back up and I
turn back to
Christ and his grace is sufficient his
grace covers me all right um now this
isn't some excuse to now go and sin
freely you cannot do that because that
shows that your faith and your
conviction is actually a false one
you're a hypocrite matter of fact the
Bible talks about this it says this in
Romans
6 uh let me share this in Romans 6 it
says this look what shall we say then
are we to continue in sin that Grace May
abound by no means no of course not how
can we who died to sin still live in it
what does that mean meaning a person who
is living in sin walking in sin they're
they're living a lifestyle of sin but
then out of their mouth want to say oh
nope I believe in Jesus I'm good to go
no absolutely not right you cannot be
living in sin walking in sin now we're
walking in New Life we're walking in the
grace of Christ so that when we we fall
it's disgusting to us we hate it and we
don't stay in that we get out of that
right um it says do you not know that
all of us who have been baptized into
Christ Jesus were baptized into his
death we were buried therefore with him
by baptism into death in order that just
as Christ was raised from the dead by
the glory of the father we too might
walk in newness of life so this is the
Christian walk here as a Believer you
are walking in newness of life you're
not living in sin
anymore so yes you you will fall but
you're not going to stay Fallen you're
not going to walk right or live in that
Fallen State and and live continuously
and
practicing okay yeah it says for if we
have been United with him in a death
like like his we shall certainly be
United with him in a resurrection like
his we know that our old self was
crucified with him in order that the
body of sin might be brought to nothing
so that we would no longer be enslaved
to sin you're not a slave of sin
anymore for one who has died has been
set free from sin now if we have died
with Christ we believe that we also we
will also live with him we know that
Christ being raised from the dead will
never die again death no longer has
dominion over him for the death he died
he died to sin once for all but the life
he lives he lives to God so you also
must consider yourselves dead to sin and
alive to God in Christ
Jesus in this walk you are dead to sin
and you are alive to God in Christ Jesus
that is the Christian
Living so I hope that maybe cleared up
something if you did a sin how do you
like
yeah go ahe what your question if I do a
sin for example now how do I repent
actually like repent
now what should I do well you just you
you're you're continuing to turn to God
you're continuing to you're you're
continuing to turn to him to you're
continuing to you hear me yeah can you
hear me
hello I'm sorry uh can you hear me now I
can hear you just fine bro can you hear
me yeah yeah I can so I do a big S now
how can I repent for
it yeah God is a forgiving God man and
God has already forgiven you you you go
to him um it's not even that you have to
continuously ask for him but you just
simply God I'm sorry help help me to get
away from this right you despise the the
sin that you've committed despise it and
turn away from it and love God more than
than than that it's as simple as
that uh and I also have one more thing
that like why did God like come and he
couldn't have for like paid the up from
above like why did he come to pay it as
a
human because um God is Holy and he's
just yeah and so because of his Holiness
and his Justice he can't just sweep sin
under the rug bro just like a judge if
you committed a crime and you're guilty
the judge in the courtroom can't just
sweep your crime under the rug and let
you go he would be unjust right even if
you said sorry and you genuinely meant
it if you robbed a bank but you really
sorry for robbing the bank in the
courtroom would the judge let you go
just as you're crying to yeah exactly he
won't let you go he has to be just right
even if you are genuinely sorry so even
more so even more holy and just is the
god of Heaven and Earth just because you
say sorry right and even if you mean it
sorry you can't just sweep sin under the
rug sin has to be dealt with the crime
has to be paid
however he loves you too and he didn't
want he doesn't want his wrath to come
upon you he doesn't want you your soul
to be destroyed and uh in Eternal
separation he wants to commune with you
so what he does is is he takes on the
form of Flesh represents Mankind and he
takes on the punishment that we deserve
so that crime is the sin of CRI the
crime of sin is dealt with it's paid for
right and his Justice and his Holiness
is appeased it's served while also his
mercy and his grace abounds at the same
time so it with the gospel you have a
you have a scenario where God is both
just and merciful at the same time he
doesn't sacrifice either right in Islam
you have the concept where Allah may be
merciful but he's not just because he
just sweeps your sin under the rug if
you're if you're ol well enough sin goes
unpunished so he may be merciful but
he's not just so that's
insufficient okay I agree yeah yeah
yeah so that's why
man the way is Christ bro run to Christ
run to him because he's given his life
to for
you um run to him so that you can walk
in newness of Life Run run to him so
that you can have this
assurance this certainty of where you're
going next so that you can receive the
promises that the god that God has
promised us from the
beginning receive receive this man and
don't play any games with it that's what
I say do it with
urgency do it with urgency but it's on
your own time it's up to
you it's up to you
bro you know
yeah so choose today who you serve my
brother who you
serving who you serve choose
today I Think Jesus is the right
way Amen to that
bro yeah he's the right way he's the
only way
man he's the right way and he's the only
way I mean yeah I've been searching a
and now like you've answered some of my
questions yeah I guess he's the right
way
yeah
amen well brother um this this what I
would suggest I would suggest you know
it's either you can either on your own
time um when you're when you're alone
and to yourself you can confess to the
Lord you know
confess um that you believe in him as
the way you believe in him as your lord
and uh you believe in him as your
atoning sacrifice that you trust in him
for your salvation that he died for you
and he rose again for you believe that
in your heart and confess that with your
mouth the moment you do that you are
grafted in into the family of
God the moment you do that can I do it
now you can yeah you can do it now of
course of course you can do it now let
me just show you this this this verse so
that we can we can I can show you where
this comes
from can do this now man praise God then
today guys is not is not a normal live
day and we see I guess
why the spirit led me to go live today
we see it all right so look this is Chap
this is Romans chapter
10 verses uh verse 8 verse 8 to9 it says
but but what does it but what does it
say the word is near you in your mouth
and in your heart that is the word of
faith that we
Proclaim because if you confess with
your mouth that Jesus is Lord and
believe in your heart that God raised
him from the dead you will be
saved for with the heart One Believes
and is Justified and with the mouth one
confesses and is
saved so we can do this right now my
brother you ready yeah all right awesome
do you believe that Jesus is
Lord yeah I believe he is do you believe
that he died for your
sins I believe he died for our sins do
you believe that he rose again on the
third
day he did rise in the third day yeah
and do you believe and trust in him him
alone for your salvation my
brother I trust in him for our Salvation
yeah amen then
today celebrate lift up your hands and
glorify God because today you are saved
you are his and you are a brother of
Christ brother in Christ you are a
brother in the Kingdom bro and I say
welcome and I'm excited to have you br
and I'm excited for your journey bro for
real I'm excited for your journey glory
to
God glory to God now here's the next
step okay here's the next
step like I told you before find a
church get baptized right the Lord
commands us he says go out baptize them
in the name of the father Son and Holy
Spirit so the next step go get baptized
be immersed underwater and that's a
symbol of you dying
right to your old self right leaving
that old old life buried and then when
you come up from the water that's you
being ra risen again just like Christ
was and so you're risen to New Life to
newness of Life In
Christ so you let all that go the sin in
your life the disbelief in your life let
that go put it at the feet of Christ
bury it come to Christ even with your
questions with the questions if you have
doubts questions Christ invites you and
says come to me bring them to me the
Bible even says God says to the people
of Israel he said come let us reason
together so don't be afraid if there's
something that comes up and you have
like oh I don't know about that ask ask
him to guide you I mean yeah the first
problem is I I never asked about
Christianity you know like but now I've
beening for
it like into Islam immediately without
even like searching about
Jesus yeah yeah that's and that's you
know unfortunately that's a lot of
people's Journeys man a lot of people
they leave Christ before they even knew
him right and then they join up with
Muhammad without knowing him and so
that's that's what it is man but glory
to God man you're saved you are
renewed and um and you have a whole
bunch of us praying for you man we're
praying for for you we're rooting for
you and so if you have any questions
please do not hesitate to come back ask
questions you know hit me up uh you know
I'm on Instagram and stuff like that if
you have questions about a Bible verse
or anything like that hit me up man and
uh I'll try to help you as best I can
okay yeah okay thank you man of course
man glory to God man have a good day man
we got a new brother in Christ man the
angels are celebrating God is smiling
today and uh man
let's keep let's keep increasing the
kingdom let's keep increasing read the
Bible bro learn it study it and spread
the gospel to those you know okay spread
the word yeah all right take care of
yourself my man thank you man all right
God bless God bless peace peace